all right in the lobby of Ramsey
solutions Matthew and Bridget are with
us hey guys how are you hi Dave good
welcome welcome where do you guys live
we live in the little town called Jasper
Indiana ah very cool we're near
Evansville maybe yeah we're about an
hour away okay all right so I put you
about two hours from here or some change
or I guess about three about three yeah
that's true okay very cool
well welcome here to do your debt-free
scream a bunch of you paid off we've
paid off thirty five thousand nine
hundred and thirteen dollars and two
cents I love it how long did that take
you to twenty two months
making what kind of money during that
time we started making forty seven
thousand and ended making almost sixty
thousand fifty nine thousand raises in
22 months what do you guys do for a
living I'm an arborist with a tree care
company cool and I'm an optometric
technician very good so what kind of
debt was the thirty six thousand we had
about twenty-three almost 24,000 and
student loans which were all mine almost
five thousand on a credit card and a
little over seven thousand on medical
bills excellent excellent what's your
degree in forestry yes okay and what
about you what's your degree in I just
have my bachelor's in arts that works
okay very good
good for you so what happened 22 months
ago then what started this journey tell
me your story I think it started a
little bit sooner for us my mom gave me
the book your total money makeover and I
paid off let me see the note
I paid off $15,000 by myself in 12
months being my school loans half before
we got engaged
okay and when we got engaged we paid for
our wedding by doing the envelope system
so then by the time we got married we
pay for our wedding completely debt-free
and then started on our journey together
finish off finishing off the rest of the
finishing off yeah so how long have you
been married then a little over two
years it was two years in June first oh
okay
so the 36000 was since marriage yes okay
go you guys and you'd already knocked
off 15 getting into that yes
very good very cool what was the hardest
part of this because you're brand new
married you go on a tight budget
giving up the luxuries you know are the
the so-called luxuries quote-unquote
eating out you know eating out for lunch
we started making more food at home just
not going and spending money you know
doing things cost money yeah you're just
spending time together outside of not
paying for it basically and what's the
thing you're looking forward to motion
now that you don't have any payments I
think for me the ability to be able to
give you know in church just to be able
to put more into the collection basket
now and giving picking more trees off
the giving tree at Christmastime and
doing things like that actually when I
go to the grocery store now I have a
goal to spend less than $20 when I go
weekly so it's kind of become something
that is a joke between us I come home
and that's like did you hit your goal
and I'm like it just feels really really
great to be able to set a goal and
accomplish it together that's for sure
that's a big deal that really is so Matt
what was the toughest part of the whole
thing I think I think the toughest part
was was just not being able to do you
know the things that friends were doing
family was doing you know we really cut
back on where we went like vacation wise
and different things that cost us money
out to dinner hotel rooms everything
cutting back on that but you know once
we started doing it and you start seeing
little steps it just it feels great yeah
it makes it all worth it
just feel the traction you can see yeah
congratulations
yeah Matt and Bridget Evansville Jasper
Indiana $36,000 paid off in 22 months
making 47 now making 60 count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one we're blessed to be
great job you guys great job I love it I
love it I love it congratulations